oh my goodness you look like an [ __ ]
frat boy so today we're going to be
looking at each other's we've been three
months yeah three years going on three
almost yeah I mean where does it go are
you guys was it 2009 I actually don't
use Facebook very much anymore I used to
it's cool anymore well looking at all
that's fine I'll go first let's go let's
do it oh you don't have your face
showing because it's covered by a
cartoon I didn't do that though I think
I was just tagged right cuz I don't you
can't you can't you don't get tagged in
something it becomes report for your
face yeah no one wants to see my face oh
god what did you find
this is amber on national tour with
Jesus Christ Superstar which is a big
deal you look like a sweet angel and
you're listening to like the guy the
famous guy that played Jesus Neely how
rude mmm-hmm look at those bang yeah I
hate it I used to like stylet so they
would sweep around like that so I was
almost covering the whole of my forehead
like straight bangs but it swept at the
time I thought it was so cool
yeah and I have tiny eyebrows at least
over pluck them so oh my goodness this
dude I look like an [ __ ] frat boy it
used to be like faux fur so I mean yeah
it was blue 2012-2016
but I look like such a douche in that
back home that took so long to get that
out of my hair again and it like
something out of a timber and maybe yeah
is it where did I kind of like the look
I think it's terrible than me too
it's from such a random time in my life
I feel like that's the thing that
happens with Facebook is that some
random picture shows up when all these
pictures from our like our early 20s
went on Facebook there wasn't that
etiquette of like being able to say to
somebody like hey like do you want this
post it or
don't don't tag me in that right and so
just everything was going up I kind of
already had stalked his facebook when I
first met you remember but like yeah I
don't remember all the pictures so it
was funny we should look at some my
lingerie photos well we miss out really
I remember you showing me photos of like
your bangs and that was a big period of
your life the bang period everyone had a
bang period come on I mean you
definitely look better now all right
good I think you went better now - good
thank you
no more looking at my facebook though
off-limits
[Music]
you